[Music]
[Applause]
my name's Armando latekka I'm the chef
and owner of f OB in the Carolinas - so
when you say Filipino barbecue it really
is skewered meat and a chicken or pork
and it gets marinated in 7up and garlic
and soy sauce
the Americans brought over ketchup and
from what I hear from when I read there
was a shortage of tomatoes in the
Philippines
so they substituted it with bananas and
it just stuck so we use banana ketchup
like American barbecue sauces base of
ketchup so the flavors are not
unfamiliar a little sweet little tangy
smoking that's definitely a street food
you know like a little kiosk type with a
little grill on the street or you cook
it yourself
it's fine and family gatherings picnics
backyard barbecues the pork ribs is
something you'll find cooked in
different flavors and forms in the
Philippines I do mine with the homemade
banana Barbic sauce that gets slathered
on top we take off the ends turn into a
st. Louis cut and then to that we put
some ago beer onions garlic carrots bay
leaves lots of tomato paste a little bit
of oyster sauce lots of soy sauce no
salt
cuz it you know it's dry it out gets
praise for about two and a half three
hours
it sounds more tender and once it's like
kind of settled in then we'll portion it
and then we grill it and baste it again
and again until it gets that like
lacquer that kind of sticks to the top
of your teeth sticks to your fingers a
little char on it the skewers we use
pork and we use chicken just marinate
them overnight and then you grill them
be careful not to over grill them don't
cook them too much they're just super
soft and tender that's and they get base
it again with that Filipino barbecue
sauce
so in a cell comes from the Visayas of
the Philippines it's chicken marinated
in lemongrass and ginger garlic and
vinegar and then when it's grilled while
it's cooking it always gets basted with
a lot of butter and we just base it
again and again until it melts on there
when you serve it you should have some
of that anata butter so you get that
like kind of butter component with a
little acidity from the vinegar so say
pork belly in Philippines is a tiempo we
make ours very traditional we put in
onions and garlic in soy sauce and a
little bit of vinegar and it marinates
it goes on the grill we try to keep a
nice balance of meat and fat meat and
fat ratio on it and then we serve it
with a chili dipping sauce Filipinos are
crazy about their food they like any
culture I don't wanna say it's Filipinos
my link in any culture food is the
center of your own occassions right it's
really food you find the house if
they're very passionate about keeping
the flavors that way their mother cooked
it or the grandmother cook it so these
are like things that my parents cook in
the house and I always say and I tell my
cooks at one point in your career you'll
go back to what you like you are you
should learn and you should cook many
different things to get that experience
to get that knowledge but at some point
you will take that knowledge and you'll
cook what you crave you cook what you
want to eat and for me honestly it's
Filipino barbecue
[Music]
you